in situations where life is involved
there's a lot less players on 6th Avenue
right now is to stop me hottest company
away then there'd be blood splashing all
over the place
funny enough in a dead body this little
blood for turning my man it congeals
inside and mom's part of the deflation
man becomes wearing a butcher shop this
little blood
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hi everybody you welcome to episode 30
of 13 o'clock I can't believe it 30
episodes oh we see that every week
though we can't be and I said I've been
I say that every weekend and it seems
like men just like you get it you get an
episode done and then you just have to
make another one well yeah like you know
a couple days later week goes by fast
and especially when you're as old as we
are going you doing
relativity when I'm is like becoming
compressed you're like I'll do it next
year yes thank you and then next year
well then next year it shows up and
you're like holy [ __ ] which that was
like yesterday not saying that okay so
what's that so well okay so we did
necrophiles last week right and yeah
don't don't talk about and Thomas bill
and Thomas still traumatized and I'm not
trauma so can you arms it's just yeah
you are okay so anyway and then so I
thought oh well maybe we'll do something
more a little more lighthearted this
week but then we went and did serial
killers and then I thought of the two
serial killers I wanted to do yeah
because I'm kind of up on like I like
burnished serial killers for some reason
cuz I looked over there for a while and
so then it's like when I started
rereading about them I'm like oh yes one
of them was in that girl files yeah
sorry
so like you know if you're kind of
grossed out by that kind of thing you
should have two weeks in a row to do it
no no I know anything about he's in one
of these cases Tom's go right along when
I told you I'm like warning you no don't
it's always better when I'm kind of like
the audience don't like walk out at the
end again I told you oh good don't leave
me carrying the show over yeah and
Jericho shows are always really popular
wrecks I love doing serial killers I
like doing them I'm in that gang [ __ ]
yeah a lot of stuff comes along with
them though you get the Stewart killer
fanboys on there it's nothing about
their knowledge oh no it wasn't it
wasn't the 12th it was on the 13th that
that happened you know got our sins the
sources for all this stuff kind of
contradict themselves sometimes the
responses are not consistent it all
depends on who's telling you and what
date it was and how up-to-date the
information is and
and honestly it's some kind of a fun
show and it's like I try to be accurate
but if I mess something up I don't like
to do more than one take because I feel
it messes the flow up so like if I mess
something up oh well I'm not something
up it's not the end of the world it's
like you know like I said I think we
mentioned it before what we get like
kind of all people on this there's only
on the serial killer ones because like
there's something about teenage boys
either physically or mentally that are
into serial killers for some reason are
like well actual layer Mar Mar Mar Mar
Mar you know I mean they go like that
and like whatever this is a free show
you my kid shut it this is a free deal
guys you know I'm gonna have a patreon
set up you know we do this basically for
shits and giggles entertainment and you
know a lot of the podcasters are you
know they're jogging or they're doing
their walk or they're going to any room
work and there's they're killing time
you know yeah maybe they're laying in
bed listen to their headphones so you
know this is not a block of instruction
you know I mean we're not trying to
teach you anything
really we're just talking about ready
talking about [ __ ] we thank his interest
yeah and it's kinda you know and all
settle out [ __ ] and also shout out to
the person on the original night soccer
video who told me to kill myself because
my voice that was nice yeah right says
Janet local fry yeah and I guess they
were talking about me right I'm gonna
say all kinds of crazy [ __ ] well you
know what I want to say here you go
first you know it does then I'll do it
you go first please let me know hey man
that's what that's what YouTube the baby
weight I was easy with it yeah yeah that
was that was a youtube comment no and
also I'd like to say if you don't like
my voice don't listen to me okay and go
[ __ ] yourself oh well you know okay so
I'm sorry so what uh alright so today we
were talking about - oh I wanted to oh
[ __ ] I forgot to mention project
entertainment networks I'm just going to
take a look go to their patreon I'll
plug at the end - oh they're cool guys
okay alright so today we are talking
about two British serial killers and
we'll save the weirder one per second
will see bigger ones for the edge and
it's like like I said I lived over there
for a while so I kind of got into like I
bought some crime books while I was over
there
and I feel like maybe the British ones
are if they're probably kind of
well-known over here and stuff like that
but it does seem like most of the
documentaries and stuff about these guys
are British so I watched a couple of
those and about each of the guys the
first guy we're going to talk about is
Peter Sutcliffe better known as the
Yorkshire Ripper
and who's the second one the second one
is Dennis Nilsen okay who is actually I
love his little uh his little
Appalachian they call him the kindly
killer home witless
maybe you'll kind of see why but in a
way it's kind of like that weird black
Lee comic ironic kind of thing I don't
know either one of them sauces Hey
because that guy was a freakazoid well
actually is a frickin I guess they're
both still alive oh so uh my dad was in
prison you know they they are among the
very small number of British prisoners
that you know they did a sentence but
then when the end of the sentence comes
up they're like nah you can't get out
that's what well Vega was what's called
a whole life terror right so it's like
they can appeal and stuff like that but
the judge like that that okay no no no
uh your your stand-in there buddy so the
first guy were talking about Peter
Sutcliffe now Peter Sutcliffe they call
him the Yorkshire Ripper
they gave him that appellation because
at first he had kind of a similar mo to
Jack the Ripper he largely targeted
prostitutes at first although that would
change later on and though he didn't
necessarily he didn't like take out
their organs or anything like that but
he would generally pick his victims at
random and he did some pretty brutal
[ __ ] like he would usually um bashing
their heads with a hammer and then he
would like hack them up with a with a
knife or with a screwdriver or something
like that who know what step on them no
when was this this was the mid 70s okay
although they think because the weird
thing about the Yorkshire Ripper is that
not only he ended up convicted of 12 or
13 murders I can't remember I think it
was 12 or 13 but um he also was was
accused of a lot of attempted murders
because a lot of women got
and so they think that aside from all
the murders and attempted murders that
they know he did and that he confessed
to that there were probably a lot of
other attacks smoker you know that he
never confessed to her that he was never
charged with I mean because like I said
they threw him in prison forever so it's
not like you know charging him with
other stuff later is going to make any
difference okay so we're going to start
well the first one that they know was
him because it took a while for the
women to actually this is terrible but
it took a while for him to actually
start getting killed like it's your
first he started out he actually started
the first one they know was him was 1969
and that was a prostitute that he had
met he was like in a band with his
friend and he went off and got a
prostitute or some like that nineteen
hit her in the head with a rock like in
a sock right now she didn't die and she
did report it to the police the police
came to his house or his friend's house
and asked him about it and he said well
I did hit her but I just hit her with my
hand and then the cop said well she
didn't want to press charges because she
was a prostitute and her husband was in
jail for something else and so he kind
of got off with it huh now the next ones
that Bay so hoo-ha so the situation
she's just standing there trying to work
a street corner he jumps up out of
nowhere just hit her with a sock well I
think what it actually happened he was
looking for this other prostitute that
had stolen his money or so or so he
claimed okay and so I guess he was
looking for this other girl and then he
saw the other prostitutes I think he
knew who the other girl was so he went
out to talk to her and then I guess hey
I think I'm just going to whack this
woman in the head with a book because
that was kind of his MO as it developed
later he would generally just pick a
random woman either a prostitute or
someone just like walking home from work
at night or something like that and just
walk up behind him and hit him with a
[ __ ] hammer well it's free yes ha ha
ha ha it is that it is great yeah it
doesn't cost me anything for that
it doesn't cost anything reading room
record I never thought about it yeah but
you're right well that's the attitude is
gonna have she's gonna have here right
yeah and that will and I thing about him
is that he didn't really I mean he
didn't seem like a weird kid he didn't
seem like he seemed like a totally
normal person how old was he when he
started he was like in he had probably
like he had a job he was married yeah um
you know he absorbed dinosaurs yeah he
worked um you know it's different
[ __ ] he worked as a truck driver at
the time of the murders but he had
worked as a gravedigger before just you
know regular working-class kind of dude
you know how old he was when he started
I'm not entirely sure it was in 1969 so
however he'll how when was he born he
was born in 1946 so 1946 1969 -90 cortex
that was his first assault like I said
he didn't kill the woman now they know
about that so but then there was a gap
like the next assault didn't take place
till 1975
so cops are kind of thinking that
between 1969 and 1975 that there was
probably a lot more random assaults that
didn't get attributed to him maybe even
murders that they never discovered right
you know what I mean [ __ ] like that but
in 1975 you know he found another woman
who was walking through she was just
walking down the street or something
like that and he came up behind her hit
her with a hammer and then slashed her
stomach with a knife now a neighbor you
know like what's all that racket and
then he ran off okay now she lived and
then a few months later or actually just
a month later same kind of thing
this girl was a prostitute she was
walking you know walking through a park
or walking down the street or whatever
struck her from behind with hammer and
then stabbed her and he was interrupted
again she also lived and then the next
victim now there's no arrests happening
he's getting away
no he's getting away okay now but the
thing about this isn't this Bob this
will come up later the Yorkshire Ripper
case was like a huge deal in British
jurisprudence because
they had never attempted an
investigation of this magnitude before
and you have to think that this is you
know late 60s early 70s no computers
Brooke everything was on paper right and
this guy was whacking remote hammers he
was killing women you know just a few
months separated and they had never
experienced this huge like you know
number of killings and so they couldn't
the cop couldn't really handle it right
he was overloaded says he was
overloading the system and sadly you
know maybe not entirely to blame
obviously because there was just so much
paperwork you know things slipped
through the cracks
you know people got killed that maybe it
would have been prevented if somebody
would have cross-referenced a couple of
different things so you know it's kind
of a shame but you know the fact that so
many of the early victims got away you
know and reported now some of them
didn't report because they were
prostitutes obviously they didn't want
to get in trouble I thought that was
legal in England um no well it's not no
not really no way it's not really super
criminalized okay but I'm going to
misdemeanor yeah but if you know someone
who didn't want to meet Riley doesn't
want your eyes hit in the head with a
hammer he's well known I've been
whacking many of them did well that's
what I mean the thing is if somebody
comes up behind you to hit you with a
hammer yes like you think inaccurately
but if he just didn't get it quite right
or if she just like started maybe he
wasn't maybe she's trying to knock him
out with a hammer yeah it'd kill him
after he's done with him maybe something
like that yeah maybe but um you know so
and then uh later that month you know
that that one woman got away her name
was uh
her name was olive smelt I believe or
that was the one that happened in August
and there was another one and then later
on that month he attacked a 14 year old
girl she was abroad visit i I don't
think she was actually huh but she was
just walking down a lane and normative
opportunities yeah and like I said even
though a lot of his victims were
prostitutes I think in the end he didn't
really give a [ __ ] right I think he just
saw a woman walking myself so yeah I'm
gonna get that
it didn't matter if it was a prostitute
or not now at first I think because he
was just attacking prostitutes and this
is terrible but I think the public was
just kinda like Isis processes it's not
like they didn't give a [ __ ] but I don't
but people weren't like afraid because
they wanted not a prostitute
so all I'm fine run yeah so he attacked
his 14 year old girl again interrupted
he saw a like car headlights coming and
he ran off now this girl was struck five
times in the head damn she did live with
a hammer yes God but she had to I mean
she had brain surgery on his life
at the time he was actually not this was
actually not among the charges like
later when he was arrested he just
confessed to it later okay he wasn't a
suspect not no not a project and this is
happening all the things Jim Larry yeah
it's around um you know do around the
Yorkshire he leaves you know Manchester
so they had gone this was a serial
killer at this summer attempted serious
yeah well see at this point no one had
died right this was this kind of random
attacks right now 30th of October 1975
there was like five women did yeah about
five them yes now like I said some of
these they didn't know with him until
later on like one because a lot of this
a lot of the timeline you know was you
know that's hindsight right yeah you
know at the time they didn't really know
right although like I said some of the
people have reported and so they did
have kind of you know sketches or photo
fits of his face okay so October 30th
1975 this was his first murder victim
her name was William McCann and she was
a prostitute she had four children now
here's the thing in at this time in
Britain you know it was a time of
economic depression and stuff like that
so a lot of working-class women who
wouldn't normally be prostitutes I mean
some of them were married and stuff like
that but they were just trying to put
food on the table you know their
husbands were out of work or whatever so
sometimes they'd be like after my mom
yes sometimes
yeah and of against what happened though
so some of these women were you know in
dire financial straits mer and it turned
to prostitution to make money to feed
kids or whatever so well mama can you
know she had four children now she this
was in lead and Peter Sutcliffe actually
hit he hit her twice to the hammer on
the head and then he stabbed her 15
times neck chest and abdomen
hold on I'm gonna check this is the very
first one this actually this is the one
that the first one that was killed that
they know of okay so what was the date
again 76 30th of October 1975 13 o'clock
okay this was the first murder now they
did now obviously since this was a
murder so now they they bring in two big
guns and they start you know doing a
huge inquiry and stuff like that they
have thousands and thousands and
thousands of interviews and they can't
find them now in 1976 it was January
this is another murder now this is
another case of a woman her name is
Emily Jackson and she this is a whole
year later yeah well no this was the the
first murder was October 1975 the next
one was January 9 26 it was only a few
months these are only a few and actually
his assaults were only like a month or
two apart okay so he tell bet he's going
to right he's going out there regularly
yes pretty much yeah
so the next one this is another
situation this one's woman was a Emily
Jackson she was 42 years old and she was
also married they had children and that
she was using the van to go out and turn
tricks to make money you know to make
money for the family now she was um she
was hit in the head also she was stabbed
51 times with a screwdriver and he also
stomped on her leg which left a boot
print okay which was a clue you know
obviously now so they knew that he wore
size 7 shoe
you know and like I said because of the
assaults they kind of knew what he
looked like they knew that he was a
dark-haired man that he had a beard
mustache and blah blah blah because some
of the photo fits if you see like some
of the photo fits that the different um
people made they do actually look a lot
like him right so you know the fact that
it took so long to catch him is kind of
sad but like I said 70s understandable
they didn't have computer
so now the next woman didn't die she was
just she wasn't a prostitute she was
just walking home from a party and and
he I guess picked her up because she was
hitchhiking or something like that and
he just picked her up and then he was
going to kill her so he beat her up and
but she lives now but she did have a
miscarriage she was pregnant at the time
did she just drive yes okay and so you
know he has just been he's going on in
this way 1977-1978
all this kind of [ __ ] and it's just
getting worse and worse and like I said
some of their prostitutes and some of
them he really [ __ ] him up a lot now
how does she describe him
same thing they described him as they
said he had you know a lot of dark hair
dark hair dark eyes beard mustache you
know well what kind of guy was Amy
because it's a workman or weird nice the
worker taking tools on yes well he was a
truck driver he's a truck driver so um
you know so he murdered a couple more
prostitutes mutilating them and stuff
like that now in June 1977 he killed a
sixteen-year-old girls not a prostitute
and then the whole area just went
apeshit because before you know like I
said oh I'm safe I'm not a prostitute
blah blah but this was just a teenage
girl walking down the street or walking
through a park or whatever and when she
got murdered kind of all the stuffs got
you know pulled out and stuff like that
I think it's funny that he's doing this
all in one area and they haven't been
able to catch Mike it's a big area you
know he kind of goes around he goes um
you know leaves Manchester so if you
know these are big cities right and like
I said most of the women he's attacking
her prostitutes so you know but this
woman wasn't now here's the thing okay
let me get to the let me get to the
thing okay so they had the boot print
they had um tire tracks at some of the
crimes now at one of the crimes what
ended up happening was this one girl
that he killed now she wasn't found
until 10 days after he killed her he's
found
she was found in a field somewhere he
what had happened was he had given her a
five-pound note you know paying for sex
which well what a deal but happiness was
a second yes that's sorry that's
terrible but um but then like after he
killed her and left her
I guess he later thought oh that five
pound note could be traced back to me so
he went back to the scene to try and
find it and take it back except she had
put it like I guess she put it in like
this secret compartment in her purse and
I don't know where her purse went and so
he couldn't find it so for some reason
he just mutilated the body and then
moved it somewhere else huh but they did
eventually find it but immediately what
he try to prevent ID yeah he tried to
cut her head off and simpler but he I
think he was trying to make the mo a
little bit different to her when
necessarily you guys you're lucky then
guy how do you straight how do you trace
a fleck Tobit biggest here's what
happened
so the the authorities did find the
device found out and you know because
they have serial numbers he's like well
they traced it to hit it but it had been
in someone's wage packet like you know
it came from a certain of it came from
the Bank of England it came to the
certain area the bank to pay you know
the wages oka of XML these amount of
companies okay so they narrowed it down
to 8,000 people who could have received
this five pound note in their pay packet
huh and he was on that list and they did
interview him right but he had alibis
you know his wife stood up why don't you
was here all night I we were at a
housewarming party or whatever so the
sad thing is that over the course of the
years that this [ __ ] guy is doing
this the police interviewed him nine
times huh
nine times man and later on like asses
but like I said they didn't have any
computers if you look there's cut a
couple documentaries about it it's
fascinated a still have like all the
paperwork right
there was so much paperwork from this
case that they had to reinforce the
floors and it was like it was like a
600,000 index card they were writing
tips and writing information down on
these little index cards and then filing
them alphabetically
they had like all these all these police
ladies like doing it and so like I said
in a way it's not surprising but it took
so long because they had so many tips
and here's another thing that happened
and this is probably the saddest thing
of all you know true toward the end of
his reign of terror the police received
a tape and it purported to be from the
Ripper so this guy's on the tape saying
you know you guys are no closer to
catching me and blah blah blah
you know just like the referee was
taunting the police then he sent letters
and stuff as well okay now in one of the
letters he claimed that he had killed
this other woman he said oh you guys
think it's seven victims but really is
eight and he took credit for this other
murder that they didn't know that they
hadn't associated with him so now here's
the thing the cops were torn some of the
cops are convinced the guy on the tape
that's him and we need to follow this
lead now some in the cops were like I
don't think that's him I think it's a
hoax but in the end
sadly they went with the cops that
thought it was really him
yeah and the problem was they spaced so
they started calling him worse I Jack
because of the accent they narrowed the
accent down to a very particular town
called Castle town in Sunderland and so
you know this town that they thought it
came from was only five thousand people
so they went to that town they played
the tape for everybody that lives there
is anybody know this guy who is this and
stuff like that they couldn't find
anybody that knew him and all this other
kind of [ __ ] and it was just diverted
the investigation for ages and ages and
it wasn't him no it was some guy named
John humble just some drunk drunk guy
hit that one now that guy got eight
years of prison for doing that for doing
that hahaha because that's just not
funny yeah because of that diversion
yeah three more women got killed all
right because they were going down there
on out which
I said what can you do what if it was
him it could have been him right but it
wasn't sees it because they thought the
guy in the cape as a Geordie accent is
it but you know the real guy did not
talk like that so that's why and also
one of the letters that this freak sent
they got a little bit of saliva off the
sand and they didn't have DNA then but
they could blood type yeah and they said
oh he has a really rare blood type only
six percent of the population has that
right so and they thought that the blood
type matched like some of the evidence
from some of the images and it was also
a thing where one of the one of the wind
that got away
asked him about like what type what type
of car the guy was driving and she
misidentified the car okay so there was
a lot of things that conspired yeah this
guy not getting caught but like I said
they did interview him nine times they
interview about the five pound note they
interviewed him about you know various
things about the car and stuff like that
but they have that eventually appended
to him well what ended up happening and
oh and here's the funny thing too I was
watching a documentary about it and they
said they had showed like photo fits
like I said from the from women that got
away
and in retrospect they look almost
exactly like them they were very good
yeah you know photo fit and they had to
say interviewed his brother on there and
he said when I saw when the photo fits
on TV is like wow it looks just like my
brother Peter cyclist Ron he's like oh
that's funny and then he was like joking
with Peter SEC looks like that it looks
just like you uh probably like and he's
like yeah and and then the brother said
man if they catch that guys to cut his
balls off and then he could have been my
brother got really upset and I started
sipping he's like I didn't get a Kia Rio
brothers circular you know but anyway
what ended up happening was in 1981 so
even he killed people like all the time
killing assaulting whatever and 1981 he
was pulled over by the police he had a
prostitute in his car and they pulled
him over like on this waste ground or
whatever and then the cops ran his
plates and discovered that the plates
were not the plates that were registered
to that car switch this way front right
so they were going to arrest him
now he said oh I gotta go take a leak so
the cops were like okay
he went around the corner took a leak
and then he came back and they sue the
police station now the cops went back to
the scene the next day and they found
that when he's going to take a leak he
had dumped a hammer or a screwdriver
like behind the wall so then they were
like oh Jesus Richter and they were so
[ __ ] happy that they finally caught
this [ __ ] but like I said it was
so sad that all of this time they just
they had interviewed him he'd been in
there so many times and they just never
caught him
now when they got said this is kind of a
weird detail too now it's not real clear
because I call you to Wikipedia page and
stuff like that now some sources say
that he raped the women and some don't
really mention it however a book came
out in 2003 about the case and they said
that when Peter Sutcliffe was brought in
and they knew that he was the river and
they stripped him underneath his clothes
he was wearing a v-neck sweater except
he was wearing it upside down like so
the legs where the sleeve so like
there'd be a v-neck like right where his
[ __ ] was yeah if you could pop it up so
he could pop it out usually I suppose
and then also the knees were reinforced
like a padding okay that way you could
climb around a stroll yeah yeah so you
know no weird that's how you could rape
in comfort yes
again Oh like that special freak anyway
so they finally caught this [ __ ]
right raped technology right yeah what's
a very simple rape technology oh my god
this dude is [ __ ] crazy so so he gets
some that he finally gets her I feel
like finally caught the you're sure
after all these years after all his
[ __ ] stress and like I said if you
see that the what do you call it this
like in news footage of them
transferring him into van and just the
whole like all these [ __ ] you know
Yorkshire people not only just worthless
scream die welcome back sir but they're
always scared you know it's like it
[ __ ] but so it's like they're all
just screaming at the man I thought that
was very funny now um so he got arrested
for you know he got arrested you get
charged with 13 charges of murder now he
tried to pull the diminished
sponsibility thing okay and like he
seemed like he was kind of trying to go
for a little crazy oh well I killed all
these women because when I was a
gravedigger God spoke to me through one
of the gravestones yet told me that I
needed to rid the world of prostitutes
because and I'm just like all right yeah
[ __ ] so yeah so um yeah the judge
and stuff was like nah man
so is this got a little weasely guy like
Gary Ridgway or these no he's a pretty
normal looking like working-class kind
of big dude and like I said he was a
truck driver and [ __ ] like that so trial
only lasted two weeks and they're just
like Janna and they're not going to let
him out and also this might make
everyone happy but he has been in prison
he's been in prison and he trench for
the hospital for when he was at
Broadmoor Hospital for the criminally
insane or whatever and then they put him
back in prison
he has had his ass kicked by other
prisoners so many times like you do like
you do like that no I mean like other
prisoners try to do tell him he was
blinded in one eye by one person who
[ __ ] stabbed him yeah he's been
stabbed and beat up and it's like
there's pictures on the internet if you
look his face is all [ __ ] up and
everything like that but you know like I
said they're never going to let this
[ __ ] out and they have no idea
why he did it you know was really
they said he was kind of you know
sources are unclear some friends of his
that I was kind of had a fascination
with prosecutor he visited prostitutes
or he had a thing about like voyeurism
like he would like to walk like follow
dudes with prostitutes and like watch
him huh but other people said nah not so
much and it's like he seemed in a lot of
ways like just kind of a normal
working-class dude and just all of a
sudden I'm just going to start hitting
women with hammers yeah whether they
were hookers or not yeah and like
anytime you start getting up lying
because oh that must be Sam he's out
here yeah I think it i think if the in
the end i think he didn't really care if
she was a hacker or not i figured if a
woman was walking around by herself here
and then just hit her cuz it what it was
for she's get the fritz like he says
yeah but yeah so on he's actually a
still alive but he got beat up a lot in
prison which you know no one feels bad
about that and i really don't think
they're ever going to let him out
imagine not but staffing is much much
later his original friend that he had
been with the first time when he hit the
prostitute with the rock yes that friend
had actually written a letter to the
police in like 1979 1980 yes and said I
think I know who's doing all did i do
right and garroted here's his name
here's his address and everything like
that but it got filed and down Ottawa
you know and yeah it was quite a shame
and there was actually the police
department you know if you want to
interviews with the guys now they feel
super bad about it just like yeah of
course you do yes especially those last
three women who they think probably
wouldn't have gotten killed if they had
gotten their [ __ ] together but you know
like I said it sucks but I never there
wasn't much they could have done yeah
you know and I ever heard of this no
computers no cross-reference and you
know and they had so many leads and so
many tips and so many hoaxers and stuff
like that so anyway um okay Yorkshire
room that's the your car never heard of
that one yeah so what one of England's
most prolific serial killers okay and so
now we're going to take a break and
after the break we're going to talk
about the [ __ ] freakazoid known as
Dennis Nilsen I don't know this one is
it okay yes well okay
well brace yourself alright this one
better be good because there's more very
good you're gonna get mad again to get
all batting in it okay promise okay so
we're going to take a break we'll be
back in just a minute a lot of people
who make stuff up for a living make
stuff up New York Times best seller
Jonathan Mayberry told us Oh Oprah's
Book Club favorite sue Miller como do
you sort of take a character and make
some bad things happen how could you
have time to do that we colored them
just like at a cocktail party except to
your headphone join us every Thursday
for the liar's club odd cat a slightly
unhinged podcast where storytellers
interview other storytellers available
on project Entertainment Network iTunes
and everywhere projects to herd
[Music]
subculture corsets and clothing is our
favorite store for unusual clothing
shoes and accessories they offer a wide
selection of men's and women's clothing
at great prices so culture also offers
the cool selection of shoes and
accessories steampunk gothic apparel
retro corsets and so much more at
subculture corsets and clothing
check out subculture online at
subculture corsets calm that subculture
courses calm make sure you use the
discount code 13 o'clock for a 10%
discount subculture corsets calm or
visit their store in Jacksonville
Florida just off i-95 has it stood on
the Lord beers - pot head hosted by me
mr. Frank
the song is the Chokey podcast of the
bizarro fiction genre and those you're
right weird and revered are gonna love
this anyone and the bizarre and weird
quick thrill so Janice here every Monday
presented exclusively by the project and
her team intent Hollow Earth graphic
design by Jenny Ashford
specializing in posters and flyers
special rates for fans at heart quick
turnaround time
books and TV covers
consultations through email or Skype
logos and packaging
payment through PayPal
as in promo materials satisfaction
guaranteed visit the Facebook page of
Hollow Earth design or email pecking ate
a hot meal calm
[Music]
right we're back talking about British
serial killers now this half of the show
is probably a lot less pleasant it's not
like first Africa isn't but uh yeah so
this guy Yorkshire Ripper is kind of
standard to me that is a lot like the
like doctor for how I get river but he
would have Jenny wasn't cut them up is
best
yeah and a hammer thing that's that's
weird and like I said it doesn't seem
like like he didn't really have a motive
really he just seemed like a regular
dude usually gun we've done with you
societal yeah just an apple yeah now
this guy okay Dennis Nilsen okay this
guy had a little bit more not a super
weird childhood but you know he was kind
of you know quiet kid whatever and he
actually part Norwegian his dad was a
Norwegian and his mom was Scottish so he
was born in a little from a remote area
of Scotland and was real close to his
grandfather's grandfather was a
fisherman so he grew up on fishing boats
and [ __ ] like that no his grandfather
died when when Dennis was six years old
and later he claimed that his
grandfather died he died he had a heart
attack when he was out on a fishing boat
and they brought the body back and put
it in a big box and put it in the house
and Dennis said that his mother you know
said to him oh there's your grandfather
he's sleeping yeah you know I mean and
he thinks that this was kind of the
point where love and death kind of
became one thing like in his mind but he
says he's not really sure he doesn't
seem super um like you can walk
interviews or something like that if he
is totally creepy but he's creepy
because I doesn't do this time where to
say he's creepy because I was not creepy
did he seemed normal and very very
matter-of-fact yeah and he also doesn't
really seem to have much insight into
his own behavior he's just like I don't
know you guys should figure that I don't
know why I do it anyway okay
and also and and I think too that he
wanted to get caught okay it seemed like
all right what tells the story now the
way he let's let's work from the way he
got caught and then we'll work back
they've been doing it for several
several years it's between about the end
of night
seventy-eight and beginning of 1983
which is when he got caught and what was
it with his seventies see that's what
you don't really you were alive in the
seventies yeah and your time but there
were so many serial killers it seems
like all your big-ticket serial killers
seventies and eighties like yeah late
60s to early eighties and we don't
really see that type of [ __ ] anymore
maybe because it's so much easier to
catch people now like you can catch them
before they go on to be internet
internet interconnectivity between
people somehow release some of the
pressure
maybe because like back then it seemed
like users which isolation and I think
that might have happened to a little bit
in Venice Nielsen's case because he was
gay or bit or maybe bisexual or not real
sure he wasn't like a super sexual
person by sex but um you buy up
something feel cyclist yeah we're all
like that that's a real quick but yeah
but I mean he you know he was an
unremarkable child really when it when
he left school at 16 and he joined the
army he was in the Army for 11 years and
he trained as a cook or actually as a
butcher or which would help him later on
okay and then after he got out of the
army he actually joined the police force
okay
although he was only in for about a year
alright um they said for some reason he
really liked regimentation right yeah
you know which I guess a lot of these
kind of guys do and I like that yeah I
like that better not be a serial killer
nope don't confess right now if you are
not just I love it I love the arm yeah
but so and then after he left the police
force he could he got a job at a job
center like helping people get jobs so
he was a civil servant basically now how
he ended up getting caught cuz let's go
and then we'll work backwards because
this is pretty [ __ ] gross
he lived in this exactly a really nice
house there's still pictures of it but
it had been divided into like several
different flats now he lived in the
Attic flat and people started to
complain that the drains in the house
were all backed up like you nothing
would drain and it was just really
really bad
mahalo there was a really horrible smell
getting a bad feeling
so somebody called and complains the
drain guy came out and when they went
down there they found like all these
chunks of stuff liking in the train yeah
I see any members yeah they will
initially know what it was but they said
when they thought they said it's just it
didn't look good so they called the cops
isn't this the one where it was a pipe
coming out from the top floor running
down the side yes yes I remember seeing
this yeah ever see yeah I don't know all
the details but I remember that so yeah
so they found chunks and they did they
thought it looked on suspicious it's all
white yeah it'll weigh and and so they
called the cops and the cops came the
cop said yes that's human tissue
they also found some human bone
fragments and things like that and they
said now from where the blockage was
they said the only places could be
coming from is someone on the top floor
flushing this down the toilet bra so
they go up to the top floor they wait
for Dennis to come home from work and
they say we want to talk to you about
your drinking and he says I didn't know
the police were interested in dreams he
said oh well we found human tissue in
there he goes oh that's awful
and then the cop is like where's the
rest of the body
yes and Dennis doesn't even fight he's
like oh it's some in bags in the
wardroom
next are like in his bedroom like he was
totally calm and [ __ ] like that
yeah and they're like okay well you're
under arrest buddy I remember and the
funny thing oh it's not I mean it's not
honorable
yeah but the funny thing is that so so
they go in his room and they find the
Wardrobe and they just smell it
awful yeah they said it smelled awful
and they're just like [ __ ] deaf
obviously and they open these big bags
there's [ __ ] what you call them this
what is this like air freshener thing
there's like air freshener staff yes go
no oh my god
dang and so they'd open the bag for
breeze on some [ __ ] like that yeah
but not elegant I know but um yeah so
they opened these bags and there's a
pieces pieces of people and action so
after they found that so they're
questioning dentists and they couldn't
tell because the bodies were all cut up
they couldn't tell how many people it
was alright so at first they just
thought it was one or two people so they
asked him okay Dennis um how many people
are we talking about is it one or two
and Dennis just very calmly says oh I
think it's fourteen or fifteen actually
and they're just like wow yeah so the
body parts must have been in there for a
long time we'll see what happened was he
had only lived in that upper flat for a
little while at that my wife now before
that now no one else in this apartment
could smell this they did but they had
kind of been - oh it must just be like
some something wrong with the sewer or
something like that like didn't you know
nobody thinks they're upstairs neighbors
like cutting people off what thing is is
that decomposing flesh has it it does
have a berry did you know that there's a
dead animal yeah yeah are people that
that naive that job is I get I don't
know you know that that's not rotten
garbage yeah I know it's not sewage
smell yeah I know what dead things smell
like oh yes maybe people don't know it I
thought everybody knew it dead people
surely find it well feels like it's not
dead people you know just get a dead
animal so all yes well no I meant about
yes very distinct odor yeah like I said
so so what ended up happening he had
only lived in this flat for a short time
now and he had killed three people in
this flat okay but prior to that he has
lived in another house and he was
totally forthcoming like he totally told
the cops yeah you probably want to check
out my old address um you know there's
all kind of bodies on the garden there
although he had burned a lot of them
right so here's here was his modus
operandi Dennis Nilsen like I said he
was a gay guy right and he so he would
kind of go to clubs and he would pick up
you know random yeah strays yeah a lot
of them were homeless you know drug
addicts and it's like
you probably need over there background
first probably um not always not always
um I don't think he was really that
picky it's just whatever he could get
although it should be said that some of
his victims have never been identified
they did manage to identify some of them
because some of them he didn't know what
their names were or he only knew their
first names or he's like oh that was
just you know the guy from Glasgow I
don't really know his name or he grew at
what he would do is he would go kind of
Cruise in the bars yes and he would pick
up you know a young pretty man and he
would say and especially once it didn't
have a place to stay and he's like oh
you know come and stay around my flat or
whatever and he would be nice for them
he would like you know give him drinks
he would listen to music you have a
reason in it this was you know he was a
bit older he was 38 okay to go back to
the thirties forties yeah and um and
stuff so and then he would bring them
home now the weird thing about him now
what you would usually do he made like a
like a ligature usually out of his hi he
also had like a tie with a piece of rope
and he would get them drunk strangle
them see his thing was he wasn't super
into killing them like he didn't get any
pleasure out of actually killing them
he just wanted their bodies yeah to stay
with him it sounds like you ever Dahmer
yeah he's like the British Jeffrey
Dahmer that's the Rope considered and
actually the book that was written about
is called killing for company and that's
actually the name of the song that I'm
going to put at the end to my life swans
because it was it's about him but um so
it seems like because he had boyfriends
at the time but it almost seems like
that he didn't have a lot of real
successful relationship and I think he
had kind of resigned himself to the fact
that he was always going to get
abandoned right so he would kind of pick
up these really young pretty boys that
didn't really have anywhere else to go
that's just like every yeah and he
didn't want them to leave him right so
what he would do is he would you would
get them drunk he would strangle them if
they were still alive he would he would
drown them in the tub and then he would
wash them in the tub sometimes he would
get in the tub with them
yeah and then he would put them in his
bed and he would sleep with them now he
says that he never actually penetrated
them like sexually penetrated or
although what he would he would either
masturbate over the bodies or he would
kind of like stick his dick in between
their size and like rub one out that way
yeah you know I mean so he would do that
kind of stuff
now obviously after a while the bodies
would start to decompose okay at which
point he would usually cut them up
because like I said he was a butcher so
he was very good at that he would cut
them up and he would put them under the
floorboards and some of the bodies that
they found in his first residence had
been in there for like a year and a half
life had been under the floorboards now
sometimes after a while he would drag
the bodies out his in his first
residence he had exclusive use of the
back garden so he would drag them out to
the garden and he would put them on a
pyre and then he would put tires on top
of it just to mask the smell when it
burned you know I mean so he was just
melt burning rubber that word he lived
set on Oh England where you start
burning tires it makes a lot of black
smoke yeah that was Debra a lot of
attention why did they just bury these
things deception well then what he would
do with what you would do then was that
he would burn it and then he would crush
up the bones that were left now when
police after police caught him they
found like over like thousands of bone
fragments forth in his yard of the first
house now see what happened was when he
moved this is why I'm saying I think he
wanted to get caught
because when he moved from his ground
floor flat to the Attic flat he didn't
have access to a garden anymore so it's
like not easy to hide body so he so he
thought to himself and he said this to
the police he said I hope that would
make me stop okay you know what I mean
and because like I said once the police
caught him he was just found like oh yes
you got me and he was very forthcoming
huh he wrote pages and pages of stuff
like trying to trying to help them like
try to remember like trying to identify
the zeros like I'm sorry I can't
remember all their names and he's like
he looked like this he has this tattoo
or whatever and it's like so and he did
tell
the investigating officer he's like if
you guys hadn't caught me it wouldn't
have just been 15 murders it would have
been 150 right I couldn't stop myself
and um and it was weird because like I
said he had a regular life he had a
regular job yes but you know just some
weird [ __ ] oh I understand these guys
can keep something that's been around
for that amount oh it really
he thought he like he liked it he likes
dead bodies he thought they were
beautiful and start getting rotten he
died he liked that well not really
here's the weird thing too because when
they started getting rotten sometimes if
he still had them yeah cuz sometimes he
would get rid of them periodically if
they were so rotten like if it was a
particularly nice looking specimen he
would like put makeup all over the over
the rotting part okay what better
business also I forgot to mention too
that when he moved to the attic
apartment and he had a party time he
kept them wrong he kept wrong with his
hands type of problem one yes I told you
I want you doing this to me I also
forgot to mention that when he moved to
the attic flat and he had to you know
dispose of the body by cutting them up
into little pieces and flushing them
down the toilet which is how he ended up
getting Cox's the drains were backed up
he would also cut off their heads and
boil their heads in a pot on the stove
to get to separate the flesh so he could
cut he could pull the flesh apart and
pull down the time yeah so yeah and um
yeah and you know I'm very sorry
really I've done I didn't realize it's
like I just we wanted to do another
serial killer show and I said I will be
doing one boiling and boiling and
cooking rotten head yeah I didn't eat
touching him yeah but now here's another
thing this is why like I said they made
a documentary about is called the kindly
killer and this is why because some of
his victims got away yeah because he let
them go
okay there is one guy in jail well no
what I got happening after they caught
him they discovered one guy I think you
see miss Daniels daughter I think he was
the one now he had been he got picked up
by Dennis Nilsen they went back to their
apartment they were drinking stuff
that he's like I fell asleep and when I
woke up he was trying to strangle me now
he um you know it knocked him out but it
didn't tell him he said when I next woke
up he was he had me over the tub and he
tried to drown me right
and he went unconscious again but he
didn't die so Dennis thought he was dead
and he puts the kid in his bed and he
falls asleep next to what he thinks is
the dead kid all right now the kid wakes
up yeah and then the craziest thing is
that he wakes up and then Dennis wakes
up and he realized the kid is still
alive huh and he doesn't kill them he
likes nursing him back to health it was
him go and buy his ex-wife I don't know
that I guess he just felt bad because
like I said it seems like and later he
said that and like I said what do you
think what'd he do school in this guy's
house for with all that stinky smell in
there and everything all the dead bikes
there not been a suspicious you know I
yeah well some of them I guess yes and I
need the drugs they need that good or
they need the money or they need the
food okay in a place to say and like I
said a lot of them were homeless
and one of the saddest ones that I'm one
of the saddest ones was a guy named
Malcolm he was a drug addict and he had
kind of he had blacked out like in front
of Genesis apartment and so Dennis took
him in and gave him food and all his
other stuff and then he let him go like
you know he's like oh you know have a
good time away and Malcolm came back to
the house later to spank him and then he
killed him and I was like that is
[ __ ] ice cold dude but there's some
of the people he let go so it's almost
kind of like he had this weird thing and
like I said whenever they interviewed
him he just seemed very calm and he
almost seems not confused really but he
doesn't really know why he does it
he's almost just kind of like and like I
said he's like I just can't stop doing
it I don't know what you know and he's
like and I don't get any pleasure out of
killing them that's why he tries to do
it and he and he was very insistent but
he's like you know I told them quickly
as if they didn't feel anything you know
they were drawn every day yeah so I
think it was more a case of he had like
these crazy weird one he had like a
weird necrophile type of thing
I think he liked having power over
something that couldn't write back and
he also liked him something that
couldn't leave him right because they
said some of the bodies he was like
leave him in his apartment he would talk
to him like they were a real person and
sure like that and he would keep him
under the floorboards and bring him back
out and talk to him and sleep next oh no
I don't like that so [ __ ] messed up
ii messed up so you know his trial was
in 83 and he was actually charged with
six counts of murder two charges of
attempted murder he actually killed they
face between 12 and 15 people but some
of them they could not identify and
because you know the parts were cut up
and there were no records and stuff like
that
so they're not really sure right but you
know that was enough oh that's a good
one I expect any I've actually I saw a
little bit of this cake on television
yeah I think I did got the backing it
was aware he was weird and it was the
same kind of thing where at the trial he
tried to argue just like the Yorkshire
Ripper did that diminished
responsibility like oh I would get drunk
and I would go you know I didn't really
know he didn't say nobody not really
Wayne who was these guys try these but
he well I guess that's all they can do
because he'd already confessed he said
you had already confessed he's going to
get life yeah England's they're not
going to deny given the death no they
don't think they have a death penalty
there so why even fight it I know what
to do I mean I think yeah you're going
you're not getting out yeah you might go
get like you're either going and really
hard with this man up yet did that [ __ ]
I did that [ __ ] it was cool is Sesa but
like I said like I said the creepiest
thing and actually at the beginning at
the beginning of the show I played like
a little bit of bomber his own actually
[ __ ] I also I also have those [ __ ] you
know I did would you do I forgot when we
were doing the part of the Yorkshire
Ripper
yeah I actually had audio of that tape
of the fake the fake guys say says they
said to the thing and oh yeah what would
you put it in there like as well put it
at the end yeah but but at the beginning
of the show that voice at the beginning
that was Dennis Nilsen and like I said
it's very creepy the way you know that
he's just very man or a matter-of-fact
about because they were like well was
there a lot of blood and stuff like that
all you know by the time I cut him off
you know they were usually that has been
dead a while there wasn't as much blood
she was thankful but he also would like
cover the floor with plastic and said
like that he would take all his clothes
off there it is so you know he was
thinking ahead I guess but um
I know and you know it's kind of gross
is like you know the pot that he usually
boil the heads and simply that it's in
theirs in Scotland this I called the
black Museum you know they're the you
know that's kinda odd in that same pot
that he'd boiled it Henson would he use
that popper cook you know what I don't
know I bet you do you probably did
[ __ ] ass what's so [ __ ] her is
this is work aware but yeah so they kind
of tried to say I don't have any image
responsibilities or something like that
but low enough but the judge was kind of
again the judge was like that you're not
getting away with that Hillary no sense
oh yeah so uh yeah yeah so so that guy
went to prison and the [ __ ] yeah
pretty much you [ __ ] [ __ ] boat I
don't care about this no get mad again
all right okay well luckily advantages I
told you I told you this was going to
hell in it and went whenever but before
it's time for it to take its toll on me
you know I started thinking about it and
there's the ramifications and the impact
of it you know I mean and I'm just like
I start glitching out like that man I
don't like that at all I know they're
dead yeah I know
yeah sorry but uh anyway well I'm sure
there was a lot of other and like I said
okay what I'm going to do right now like
I'll do the end burtom be some okay Chum
so I'll do the end part right now and
then before like I wanted to play it
like that that fake your shrimp or take
away so I'll I'll play that and then
after that like I said our musical
interlude but our musical interlude is
going to be from actually when my
favorite bands you don't like them but
one of my favorite bands Swan Helen and
they and they wrote a song actually
called killing for company and it is
about senate's know that role that
people think that is about Jeffrey
Dahmer but it's not it's about Dennis me
okay so I'm just going to play a couple
minutes of that and so I guess that'll
do it for this episode before he just
says yes goodbye
so anyway if you liked the show
please go to the project Entertainment
Network patreon and give them a buck or
two they have a lot of cool podcasts on
there too you like our YouTube show then
please subscribe to our channel 13
o'clock podcast and go you know follow
us on Twitter and go like our Facebook
page which are also called 13 o'clock
podcast and now we're going to hear from
the face Yorkshire Ripper and then we're
going to hear from swans talking about
Dennis Nilsen and then that'll be the
end of the show so hope you guys liked
this disgusting episode bye I'm look I
see Austin Eleanor look luckily I have
the greatest respect for you George
with Lord you want one needed touching
they know who and for years ago when I
started I reckon y'all bones I let you
down George
they call me much good come in
[Music]
I'll keep you company
[Music]